- And now it's time to play
Hit Me With Your Mug Shot.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
The perfect game for you guys.
I think you're gonna
be very good at it.
The SmokingGun.com
is an amazing gallery
of mugshots from
around the country.
I'm going to show
you some highlights
and for 250 points,
I want you to speculate
on what the alleged crime
that these alleged perps
allegedly committed,
(audience laughs)
to get them taken downtown.
- By the way, lawyers
want you to say that.
Where there's
smoke, there's fire.
(audience laughs)
- Good to know.
- If it got past a grand jury,
they (bleep) did it.
(audience laughs)
- All right, first one.
This contemplative soul,
(audience laughs)
also know as Latino Doug Benson.
(audience laughs and cheers)
Yes, Travis.
- Sniffed glue,
spilled glue on hands,
forgot he spilled glue on hands
because he was sniffing glue,
tried to jack off
in his own mouth.
(audience cheers and laughs)
- [Chris] That's
probably what it was.
(audience laughs)
So he was caught in mid act.
Amazing. Trudy.
- This guy is guilty
of promising to take me
to Chipotle on a date,
(audience moans)
and then dropping
me off on the corner
with a coupon and
then speeding away.
(audience moans)
- You didn't chase him down?
- I went home and
worked it out.
- [Chris] Okay.
(audience laughs)
Dangle, do you want
to throw one in?
- No.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- You are worse at this
show than Tom Lennon.
(audience screams and laughs)
- But, not quite as gay.
(audience screams and applauds)
- Next one.
This professor of criminology.
(Bell dings)
Dangle.
- This is a trick
question Chris because,
(audience laughs)
I happen to know that
is the actual Hamburglar
without his mask.
(audience screams and laughs)
(audience applauds)
Yeah, it seemed funny before.
- Not funny, points
in rabble, rabble.
(audience laughs)
All right, Travis.
- I stole the last of
the lembas bread from
Frodo and blamed Samwise Gamgee.
- Okay.
(audience cheers)
(applause)
- Right in the middle
of that sentence
I thought I was having a stroke.
(laughter)
Because words just
turned into jives.
(audience cheers)
- All right last one.
This unhappy imp
(audience groans)
- Totally killed the
vibe at the drum circle.
- Yes close.
(audience applauds)
Dangle.
- He's mostly into
food (bleep)ing.
Which on paper sounds like
the perfect crime you know.